when you start to see when you aote your
brand when people no longer think of
bware as one of the best studios in in
the world and now they're just like yeah
they used to be I don't know about them
now like that that took a period of time
and that's that's a brand that got
eroded I don't want to see that for Xbox
I don't want people to be like I don't
need that even though yeah they even say
hey you don't need it because you can
play anywhere you want but but there are
people who feel internally I know I
could play everywhere but I want to
play and and and when you when if if the
when you already got struggling console
sales and if if that continues to erow
and then people you know who don't have
one are like I don't need one and they
and in state of getting a new console
gamer coming in who made you get it as a
second console which technically is as a
Game Pass subscriber lost you know that
that that's a body as well